tens of thousands of people in North
Carolina is starting to tally the damage
from Hurricane Florence early estimates
show the storm caused as much as 22
billion dollars with a B in destruction
now that would make it one of the 10
most costly as hurricanes in US history
FEMA is handing out ready-made meals
water and tarps to storm victims Manuel
Bojorquez is in Wilmington North
Carolina at a shopping center where some
stores are still closed today man well
good morning good morning gales some of
those evacuating to find parts of their
community are still devastated
businesses closed this gas station
heavily damaged and thousands of people
are still living in shelters the cleanup
here could take weeks a full recovery
much much longer housed her house under
water still under water it will be under
water for a while crystal brewer and her
son wrote at the storm surviving on only
bread and water they arrived at this
distribution center to get their first
real meal in more than four days what's
your hope right now I mean whatever
momentum gets back to normal people are
trying to kill each other around here
the once sprawling city of 120,000 is
now littered with downed trees broken
glass and boarded up storefronts
distribution centers are providing meals
and water after floods largely cut the
city off from the rest of the state for
almost four days a lot of people have
lost everything they had to be evacuated
so quickly that they didn't have time to
take anything governor Roy Cooper fears
the worst flooding in North Carolina is
yet to come and he's working to provide
temporary housing for those in need are
you getting what you need from the
federal government from your state
legislature right now we are we're
trying to rebuild businesses and roads
and bridges and infrastructure and get
people back into their homes that will
be a challenge and we're gonna ask
everybody to step up but residents like
Dennis Hickson are confident a sense of
normalcy will come back it's going to be
a while before this returns to normal
yeah we will but we'll be wilmington
strong believe me they'll see
we'll come back you can count on that
one distribution center was serving 100
people per hour yesterday for a total of
15 thousand bottles of water and 8,000
meals people here tell me what they
really need right now is eyes to try to
preserve some of that food and medicine
like insulin Nora Wow man well thank you
you know we had chef Jose Andres here
yesterday I mean this need to meet just
the basic things about water and food
every day it exists it's real yes if you
don't think about until you don't have
it
absolutely